[Música]
[Aplausos]
quando se fala em inovação a primeira
coisa que vem à mente a tecnologia né
novos apps algoritmos e tudo mais mas o
que eu venho percebendo na minha
trajetória de empreendedorismo cultural
e social
é a potência da inovação nas relações
humanas
a potência dos verdadeiros diálogos
daquele lugar de empatia de conexão de
entendimento que nenhuma máquina
consegue substituir maria farinha filmes
que já nasceu no ambiente ativista pra
trazer histórias que transformam eu vejo
e vivo isso todos os dias
foi a partir de um filme muito além do
peso que se intensificou uma discussão
muito necessária a respeito da obesidade
infantil no mundo
e foi a partir deste filme da inspiração
desse filme que vieram conversas
inéditas entre a indústria de
refrigerantes ativistas e profissionais
de saúde de direito
essas conversas resultaram na mudança de
política de comunicação da coca cola que
deixou de comunicar refrigerante para as
crianças no brasil e depois no mundo e
depois dessa conversa evoluiu quando as
principais marcas de refrigerantes se
uniram para deixar de vender essas
bebidas açucaradas nas cantinas
escolares para crianças abaixo de 12
anos
aqui a gente viu a inovação nesse novo
diálogo numa forma de te escuta mesmo
com pessoas diferentes pontos de vista
com diferentes interesses numa mesma
mesa foi transformador ver isso foi
transformador v
essas essas decisões acontecendo e tem
sido cada vez mais um outro exemplo
incrível que hoje muito de perto
foi quando a gente lançou o documentário
começo da vida
o documentário fala da importância para
a sociedade dos cuidados com os
primeiros anos de uma criança e quando
comecei a trabalhar com esse filme
o primeiro desafio que eu tive foi
procurar parceiros para potencializar a
atribuição desse conteúdo porque a gente
sabia que pra provocar as mudanças que a
gente precisa a gente precisaria falar
com muita gente e pra falar com muita
gente a gente teria que pensar a
atribuição de uma maneira totalmente
diferente e não a transformação que se
faça sozinho né pra acontecer uma
transformação social é preciso o
envolvimento de todos da sociedade civil
e da iniciativa privada dos governos e
das organizações sociais
quando a gente produziu esse filme a
gente já tinha algumas organizações
sociais com a gente e aí como eu venho
do mundo corporativo eu resolvi bater na
porta das pessoas os meus contatos da
vida de executiva afinal as grandes
marcas e empresas têm um grande alcance
neta investimento tem um grande alcance
tem bastante poder de comunicação
quando fui bater na porta dessas pessoas
eu fui bater eu fui conversar com eles
com um pedido bastante incomum que era
que essas marcas apoiassem esse filme
apoiassem esse movimento mas que como a
gente precisava chegar ao maior número
de pessoas possível que outras marcas
também pudessem participar desse
movimento e outras marcas concorrentes
também
bom quem vem e quem está no ambiente
competitivo eu como o ambiente que eu
vim sabe que isso não é nada fácil de
conseguir essas marcas brigam
diariamente pela atenção dos
consumidores e colocá los numa mesma
estratégia de comunicação seria bastante
difícil mas a gente conseguiu ea gente
conseguiu porque a gente foi falar com
pessoas
a gente não foi falar com marcas a gente
não foi falar com diretores presidente
a gente quer falar com pessoas que como
pais madrinhas tios poderiam se conectar
com essa proposta com essa causa maior
porque na humanidade que a gente se
encontra não é e foi incrível ver a
transformação do outro lado da mesa
daquele lado que eu já estive foi
incrível ver a transformação nesse modo
convencional de pensar a gente conversou
bastante sobre a importância da causa
sim mas a gente falou muito sobre a
importância dessa união para conseguir
mudança e mais ainda a gente falou sobre
o poder ea responsabilidade dessas
pessoas que estão por trás dessas marcas
empresas têm para melhorar o mundo e foi
pela união dessas marcas com
organizações do terceiro setor e com
governos das mais diversas bandeiras que
a gente conseguiu que o filme chegasse
em 85 países através da nossa plataforma
de vídeos transformadores gratuita
foram feitas mais de sete mil exibições
no mundo inteiro da cidadezinha de
mossoró no rio grande do norte até a
faixa de gaza
a gente conseguiu chegar com este
documentário numa audiência de 1 milhão
e 200 mil pessoas
e juntando filme com a série e com as
pílulas que a gente produziu chegamos em
mais de oito milhões e meio de pessoas
no mundo um resultado jamais atingido
por qualquer blockbuster de cinema em
termos de alcance intacto e essas
edições continuam que assistiu estão lá
de forma gratuita nessa plataforma ea
gente vem vindo a transformação a gente
vem vendo empresas aumentando aí a
licença paternidade maternidade
entendendo que ela tem um papel de
cuidar dos pais e das mães para que os
pais possam cuidar da infância unicef
adotou o filme como campanha oficial
pela primeira infância no 190 países
onde atua
eu contei duas histórias aqui em que
filmes foram fundamentais para provocar
essa conexão pra ver diálogo é
necessário haver conexão e filmes são um
poderoso veículo para provocar essa
inspiração que traz a conexão e todo
tipo de arte é né
a nossa distribuidora de impacto flow
olha para outros ativos culturais como
shows exposições e livros provocar essa
inspiração também a gente se tornou
sócio de uma empresa também se chama de
ang pra gente poder explorar a força da
experiência imersiva através da
realidade virtual e aumentada
eu tenho uma empresa que se chama
oficina de alegria que busca conectar as
pessoas através da música e da cultura
brasileira
aqui é um dos filmes que o golpe fez em
que você de fato entrar numa aldeia
indígena e aqui são alguns dos eventos
que a gente faz na cidade alegria pra
conectar as pessoas através da cultura e
da alegria
eu acredito demais que cultura
transforma porque a cultura é capaz de
trazer aquele lugar onde pessoas muito
diferentes com idéias diferentes podem
se encontrar e falar conversar senti
algo em comum
e aí que acontecem os verdadeiros
diálogos são dessas conexões que a gente
consegue mudanças reais aí pra mim
a inovação que nenhuma máquina consegue
mas nós seres humanos conseguiu sua
chegada
[Aplausos]